What is the volume of this box?
Drag on the box to rotate it.
So this is pretty neat.
We can actually sit
and rotate this box.
And here it looks
like everything's
being measured in meters.
So we want to measure our
volume in terms of cubic meters.
That's going to be
our unit cube here.
So when we want to think about
how many cubic meters could fit
in this box, we've
already seen examples.
You really just have to multiply
the three different dimensions
of this box.
So if you wanted the
number of cubic meters
that could fit in
here, it's going
to be six meters times 8
meters times 7 meters which
is going to give you
something in cubic meters.
So let's think
about what that is.
6 times 8 is 48.
Let me see if I can
do this in my head.
48 times 7, that's
40 times 7, which
is going to be 280 plus
8 times 7, which is 56,
280 plus 56 is going to be 336.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do one more of these.
So what's the
volume of this box?
We'll once again, we have
its height at six feet.
Now everything is
being measured in feet.
We have it's width
being four feet.
So we could multiple the height
times the width of four feet.
And then we can multiply that
times its depth of two feet.
So 6 times 4 is 24
times 2 is 48 feet.
48, and I should say cubic feet.
We're saying how many
cubic feet can fit in here?
When we multiply the various
dimensions measured in feet,
we're counting almost
how many of those
cubic feet can
fit into this box.